[Music]
owen orlando thanks for joining
spectator tv
oh and in this week's magazine you uh
wonder whether
ultimately putin has lost the plot are
you surprised by his decision to launch
a full-scale invasion of ukraine um i'm
i'm not just surprised
i'm completely flabbergasted but
actually more importantly than me um
i've just spent the whole morning um
uh on twitter and signal and facebook
and uh with all my russian contacts
several many of whom have worked in the
putin apparat in the diplomatic service
in the in his media machine
for two decades
and russians are amazed i mean people
who think they know what's going on you
know top journalists people who work for
putin in the kremlin who have been
supporting his propaganda effort for
years
they are surprised and they actually
didn't think it was going to happen
basically sunday everyone was still on
the diplomatic
channel lavrov you know everyone was
all
calling uh western claims of in a minute
invasion hysteria
and then it suddenly changed and there's
two explanations to that either that the
diplomacy was a bluff and raw war was a
plan all along
but um
or that
something changed in principle and putin
decided at the last minute for reasons
that are very hard to fathom to
completely abandon not just diplomacy
but apparently
all kind of self-interest because i
think what we one thing that we have
been saying all along are both orlando
and i is actually true is that the one
scenario in which he absolutely loses
all the diplomatic leverage that he has
all of the
strategic ambiguity that he's built up
all the allies that he's been
cultivating inside europe and his divide
and conquer
all of that he loses with a full-scale
invasion and he's invaded it's totally
inexplicable and
completely
counterproductive as i see it
well andy are you also perplexed by
recent events
yes i'm shocked and saddened and
disgusted
as everybody is um
and we're at a point where we really
can't tell what's in putin's planning
um
we can certainly tell what he's been
reading and what he's been saying and
the sort of ideologies that he's been
playing with that have led him to this
point um i think
that he has
moved in an imperial direction in terms
of sort of civilizational thinking
he's taken on board a lot of ideas from
uh people like carl schmidt to believe
that
uh there are hegemonic states of which
russia is one and there are other
entities like ukraine which are not even
to be given
uh sovereign status
um so he's been perhaps isolated too
long reading too many weird nazi jurists
and other ideologists of a pan-slav
eurasian ilk that would lead him in this
direction to think that
he is able to do this um is that a sign
of madness of dislocation from reality
uh
i think probably it is in which case i
think like many uh russian rulers of
that nature that have embarked on
foreign adventures before and i'm
thinking of nicholas the first and the
first crimean war
it will mean the end of his regime
fairly quickly
on the other hand um all the signs are
and the confidence of uh rhetoric would
suggest that they've been planning this
for a very very long time so i think
that he still has a lot of levers to
pull he still has a lot of influence to
call upon and he still has a number of
threats to make perhaps even to our own
political establishment or any political
establishment that tries to cross him
so
you know this is a kgb war as well as a
ministry of defense war um and it's it's
a war in which everything is weaponized
um disinformation social media cyber
warfare as well as troops on the ground
and and all the deployments we've seen
in the last few hours
so who knows who knows where we are it's
it would be a fool now to say that they
thought they knew what was going to
happen next
and all andrew just on the historical
perspective here i want to you mentioned
how ultimately putin um
in how he is speaking and how he sees
things he's suggesting that ukraine is
not a country it's part of greater
russia effectively um can you talk us a
bit more through his perspective on this
and ultimately where greater russia ends
yeah well i mean the the the article
that everyone cites is his long piece
slightly bizarre piece um that the
kremlin published last year july 2021
and uh he's really repeating a number of
strands that he's already made in his in
in his speeches and articles
namely that um russia and ukraine and
belarus are all one nation they all
share the same foundation and kievan
ruse
um so we saw this really come to the
fore in 2016 when he opened this
monument to the grand prince vladimir in
moscow who of course is also claimed by
the
ukrainians is the founder of their
european state for putin he's the
founder of the great russian state of
which a tripartite state if you like of
which belarus and ukraine are one so
this is his civilizational thinking i
was referring to
and in that foundation myth there's no
place for a ukrainian statehood this
again is something that you know the
ideas of carl schmidt that he's been
borrowing from uh feed into the idea
that that um
only certain cultural national
formations have statehood at their heart
so russia has a statehood and ukraine
has always been for putin um just a
borderland ukraine the original slav
word for ukraine just does mean
borderland and so it's uh then in other
articles putin has said for example that
you know ukraine as a nation state was
invented by the bolsheviks so
that you can see given the
historiography he comes from
basically soviet you can see sort of
where he's coming from i mean it's mad
but his argument is that it was only uh
the bolsheviks in drawing up the
constitution of the soviet union that
ukraine was given its first nation well
the ukrainians would say nonsense they
they would trace their nationhood back
to kievan rus or they would trace their
nationhood back to the cossack
heckmanate of the 17th century which
looked for help from russia originally
or they would point to the independent
ukraine of 1917 to 18 which very quickly
became a german puppet state and then
got embroiled in civil war before the
the soviet union was formed with a
soviet republic as part of it so uh
ukrainian soviet republic so you can see
that it's a whole mishmash of historical
ideas and ideologies
that putin is weaponizing here or
drawing from to justify his his world
view of russia as a hegemonic state in
ukraine as simply
um a subordinate state if you like or
subordinate entity which which has to be
included in a bigger civilization that's
how i think he he views the world um and
it is wacky it is it is mad it is
certainly not fit for purpose in in in a
post-1991 world where we do live by um
we hope you know international standards
and principles of sovereignty
um but that is just not how putin
um has come to see it um unfortunately
and owen where is i suppose russian
public opinion on this is there a sense
amongst the people that you know ukraine
is a part of russia or you know should
be uh more in lock-sync with it
well um
uh well first i mean just to orlando's
point i mean something um an analogy
that might be more familiar to
english or british
viewers is actually the very ambiguous
relationship between britain in the
first world war and ireland for instance
or a longer term the the
scottish kingdom's flirtation with
france that's always the the the
relationship between russia and ukraine
is of close neighbors which have
various points being part of the same
state which have been flirting with
enemies and are flirting with enemies
now the the really big question is
uh
will
russia's very rushed very amateurish
very last minute
propaganda campaign managed to swing
a majority of russian opinion behind
a full-scale invasion i don't think so
far um i personally don't believe that a
long-term occupation of all of ukraine
is anything that vladimir putin is
contemplating it's certainly not what
he's preparing his people for
but the uh
clearly defending donbass and the
russians of the eastern ukraine against
genocide is now the line
depressingly it seems that russian
viewers claim in public opinion surveys
to be
quite fantastically gullible and
uh with the program so the very latest
polls that have come out say that 50
percent uh at least support the war but
um the the the reliability of polls is
always a big this is always a big
question mark because
for instance the uh versa eom the
state controlled polling center not the
independent lavada one but literally the
state-controlled one uh came up with a
poll when they open-endedly ask
russians to name a politician politician
they trust only 21 say
vladimir putin when you ask them on a
multiple choice which of these
politicians you trust most then putin
comes out at 68 percent so is his
support 21 or is it 68 it depends how
you ask the question it's a very
ambiguous
issue um now so far um
the messaging has in the past
worked in 2008 it was a question of the
georgians have attacked south asset here
and the russian public were able to
believe that package which was in fact
somewhat true the georgians did attack
south africa briefly
that russia was responding to a
provocation in crimea there was a
gigantic preamble there was actually
three months of
profound unrest in kiev
the
revolution of dignity is the ukrainians
call it the the the
effectiveness of democratic people power
coup against the pro-russian government
of viktor yanukovych was presented as a
fascist coup and there was lots of time
to prepare the russians for that here
all of those arguments about the
fascists in in in kiev about aggression
has been compressed into 48 hours
it's amazingly rushed it's as though
they've just sort of decided to sort of
run out of the building and just grab
every single ideological argument that
they have and off the shelf and just
sort of throw it
at the russian public and see
what will happen and whether it'll stick
i mean i think that there is a profound
ambiguity uh and there's a
ambivalence i would say between the
relationship in the relationship between
russians and ukrainians because they
actually have so many ukraine russians
have close family ties with ukraine i
mean they
do indeed consider ukraine to be part of
their own country in many ways and
that's a very common attitude that it's
just a little part of our of our great
nation
um but that argument has to
that that's a stick with two ends as the
russians say is that
um the russians consider it part of
their country does that mean that
they're actually going to
allow their sons or be happy about their
sons
going to war against ukrainian ordinary
people i don't know it's the most i mean
what the one thing it is clear is that
this is the most severe
and extreme stress test that russian
propaganda has ever had to face
and
if putin loses it
then that really is the end of his
regime if
and and he's he's started it in an
extraordinarily rushed amateurish way
which has amazed and shocked even most
russians even those even many russians
who support him and just briefly on that
one of the points you've made when
you've been covering this crisis is that
you thought uh a full-scale invasion was
unlikely because ultimately putin had
not been preparing the people for it
have we seen in the past you know a few
days and start to do that do you think
the russian people are prepared for the
war that he has now announced
well that's um the messaging has changed
i mean it hasn't changed to let's
incorporate
uh ukraine into russia that's not the
messaging
the messaging is let's defend the the
russians of eastern ukraine from
fascists and genocidal killers in the
form of
uh ukrainian nationalists
so i mean even at the moment
even now that there's been this sort of
step change this complete sort of pivot
towards an actual invasion the messaging
in russian state media is still not a
full-scale invasion it's about
publishing the
fascists for
launching an aggressive war as the
russian media has been portraying it
against the russian-speaking peoples of
eastern ukraine
and orlando just finally um if we have a
situation where we talked a lot about
the risk here in terms of uh you know
putin announcing this where it could go
very wrong for him why this is by far
one of the most tricky paths he could
have picked the most difficult in fact
but were this to go to plan for putin
what does that look like and what is he
trying to do in terms of uh writing his
legacy and changing russian history
well we don't know what his plan is i
mean
so we can't really say but the
i think owen's point is a good one about
um you know support whether this would
be
um coming from the russian population i
mean still 70 percent of the population
is entirely dependent on television for
its news
so he can control that increasingly aged
part of the population
um but i i'm but i'm i
and i'm skeptical about whether um
there's a going to be a big anti-war
movement in russia because he's crushed
civil society so effectively and it's so
fragmented that people have become
despondent so we'll see we'll see about
that whether he can see it through um
and i don't think there can be a success
for putin from from this point on and
and i i i think and very much hope it
spells the end of his regime and i
suspect coming back to this this
rhetoric of defending the russian people
from genocide et cetera i suspect that
that has actually more to do with
putin's own
uh weirdly twisted reading of of post
cold war history and his his his attempt
to get back up the west for what he sees
probably as the beginning of all of this
confrontation with the west which is
kosovo because if you remember nato went
into kosovo uh supposedly to save the
albanians from genocide uh from the
serbian philosophy tradition and i think
that's the point of which the russians
see the beginning of this uh new
confrontation this new cold war if you
like with the west so it's almost as if
he's saying we
as if he's saying to the west in his own
um ideological thinking his echo chamber
as as as owen put it in his piece is
what mrs if he's saying to the west you
know i'm going to fight you by uh uh by
your own principles i'm going to call
out the genocide your your your your
your you're bringing about to our
russian speakers our people as you would
put it um although they're of course uh
citizens of a sovereign state um and and
this is um so now divorced from reality
that one wonders who it's going to
convince um other than himself and and
um the sort of mad ideologists who
surround him or who've been um
influencing his thinking
and i doubt even whether it will
convince i mean will lavrov really be
convinced by this sort of um rhetoric as
uh the occupation of ukraine becomes
more uh more and more bloody and messy i
don't know i suspect it will probably uh
accelerate any fragmentation of his own
regime between you know hawks and doves
between those who may want to return to
the diplomatic path
rather than
get russia
deeper and deeper into this mire
into which it's now launched itself
[Music]
you